madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mardi 8 août est
d'abord ce coup de tonnerre sur le tour
de france près de la moitié des
échantillons urinaires prélevés sur les
coureurs pendant le tour comprenait des
produits dopants beaucoup le justifie
par des certificats médicaux mais la
suspicion revient à grand-pas un coup de
théâtre au chili avec la décision de la
cour suprême de lever l'immunité
parlementaire du général pinochet
l'ancien dictateur pourrait donc être
jugé là même où un procès paraissait
impossible
en espagne le thé à frappe à nouveau le
président du patronat de la province de
gipuzkoa et tué par l'explosion d'une
voiture piégée
quatre militants de letea saute avec
leurs propres bombes à bilbao et une
troisième voiture explose à madrid
et puis gilles tibo est mort c'était
l'un des auteurs avec claude françois ii
comme d'habitude en anglais my way sans
doute la chanson la plus connue et la
plus reprise à travers le monde
mais d'abord le tour de france et les
résultats des analyses rendues publiques
par le conseil de prévention et de lutte
contre le dopage
un organisme indépendant près de la
moitié des prélèvements urinaires
effectué pendant le tour de france se
sont révélés positifs bien sûr bon
nombre de coureurs pourront faire valoir
les certificats médicaux qui les
autorise à recourir à des
corticostéroïdes ou à du salbutamol mais
cette révélation jette une ombre
fâcheuses sur un tour qui se voulait
être celui du renouveau
christelle bertrand après chaque étape
du tour de france quatre contrôles anti
dopage à partir des urines ont été
effectués
le premier du classement général le
vainqueur du jour et deux coureurs tirés
au sort
ce matin un fax envoyé par le conseil de
prévention et de lutte contre le dopage
signé par son président a donné les
résultats des 96 contrôle
les analyses pratiquées par le
laboratoire national de dépistage du
dopage nous révèle la présence de
produits dopants dans 45 % des
prélèvements urinaires et pour presque
la moitié des cas les médecins ont
trouvé soit des corticoïdes soit des
stimulants respiratoire soit les deux
le coureur peut utiliser ces produits
s'il fournit une ordonnance c'est le
règlement
les corticoïdes leur intérêt c'est
d'améliorer la performance
ils sont anti inflammatoire ils sont
anti douleurs ils sont autorisés
uniquement sur ordonnance une sportive
de haut niveau et uniquement en
application locale s'était d'ailleurs
pas ma crème ou lotions mais il suffit
de prendre des comprimés ou encore des
injections est d'abord une ordonnance
qui dit on vous a presque une pommade
pour tricher détourner la loi et
l'ordonnancé vous permet d'être
tranquille pour les produits ce qu'on
appelle bronchodilatateur ils sont
normalement utilisé à petite dose d'un
traitement de l'asthme mais à haute dose
ils ont un intérêt ce qu'ils font monter
la masse musculaire
là encore il ya très facilement les
moyens de tricher puisqu'il ya une dose
limite à ne pas dépasser
si vous trichez si vous en prenez
beaucoup si votre ordonnance dit qu'on
vous traite pour asthme et bien vous
êtes sauvés cet après midi ni la société
du tour de france ni les responsables
des équipes ni les coureurs n'ont voulu
s'exprimer
la conviction semble rejoindre la
suspicion qui pèse sur l'état de santé
des coureurs
ce premier bilan des contrôlés pour le
moins alarmant mais la route est encore
longue il reste encore à connaître les
résultats des contrôles epo
alors avec nous en direct de mulhouse
daniel balle le président de la
fédération française de cyclisme bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors que faut-il penser de ces
révélations évidemment ce sont des
chiffres qui vu de manière très bruts
comme ça sans sont inquiétants 45% du
coureur je crois qu'il faut pas dire de
produits dopants mais de produits qui
sont effectivement sur les listes et là
sur une liste particulière qui est la
liste des produits soumis à restrictions
et c'est ça la différence
et justement sont soumis à restrictions
mai sont autorisées avec une
justification thérapeutique et on
connaît toutes les difficultés pour
démontrer que la justification
thérapeutique est effective mais l'union
cycliste internationale a mis en place
depuis le début de l'année un livret
médical du sportif dans lequel
l'ensemble des prescriptions médicales
eux figure et c'est pour cette raison
que l'union cycliste internationale a
estimé dès la semaine dernière que à
deux exceptions près l'ensemble des
coureurs avaient des justification
thérapeutique acceptable mais comment se
fait-il et les coureurs sont des gens
qui sont pas très vert en très bonne
santé ils ont besoin frappe beaucoup de
deux ordonnances comme ça oui
effectivement c'est la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est pour ça que le
chiffre de 45
% interpelle parce que ça veut dire que
près d'un coureur sur deux était malade
ou été blessés il y avait besoin de ces
substances pour continuer à participer à
ce tour de france
alors ça c'est vraiment eu une vraie
difficulté je rappelle également que le
tour de france est la seule épreuve
sportive au monde dans lesquels les
corticoïdes ont été recherchées et on
sait toute la difficulté qu'il y à
lutter contre l'utilisation de cette
substance parce qu'elle peut à la fois
être dopantes où elle peut servir à des
fins vraiment thérapeutique et faire la
différence entre les deux n'est pas
facile évidemment ce sera aux rôles ça a
été au rôle de lucé hissera au rôle des
commissions discipline de prendre les
décisions définitives mais aujourd'hui
je crois qu'il était apte à gérer de
dire que 45% des coureurs sont des
tricheurs mais c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même des tricheurs il ya déjà des
poursuites engagées et rillieux il y
aura des sanctions éventuelles
vous savez dire que aujourd'hui le sport
de haut niveau est propre c'est ridicule
on sait très bien que le dopage existe
je n'ai jamais nié cela et pendant le
tour de france à la fin du tour de
france j'ai rappelé que le cyclisme a
fait un pas en avant important en
matière de lutte contre le dopage
ensuite convaincu cependant il reste
aujourd'hui encore un certain nombre de
problèmes à régler
je vois simplement que le cyclisme les
brand alley prend à bras le corps et
accepte effectivement que les
corticoïdes soit soit recherchée quitte
effectivement avoir des informations
quand même un petit peu brute un petit
peu dur à avaler comme celle là parce
que affirmé que ces 45 % de produits
dopants me semble excessif et je ne veux
pas chercher de fausses excuses mais
simplement ramener les choses à une
réalité qui est celle que ben le dopage
existe qu il faut lutter contre que le
cyclisme cherche à lutter de tous ses
moyens il faut pas non plus raconté
d'histoires pour dire qu'aujourd'hui
tout va bien dans le meilleur des mondes
ceux qui racontent rsa serait à côté de
la réalité et ne servirait pas les
intérêts du sport et l'intérêt du sport
c'est que le sport redevienne propre
mais c'est encore un sacré chemin à
parcourir
merci beaucoup en tout cas daniel balle
et puis pour aller dans le sens de votre
prudent je précise que jean marie
leblanc vient justement de réagir et qui
le met en garde contre toute
interprétation prématurée de ses
résultats jean louis leblanc qui est
donc le président le directeur de la
société du tour de france à l'étranger à
part le juge bluesman qui instruit le
dossier pinochet peu de gens en vérité
imaginer que le chili se décide un jour
à juger son ancien dictateur et pourtant
c'est bien ce que vient de permettre la
cour suprême chilienne en levant
l'immunité d'augusto pinochet cette fois
la voie est ouverte un procès même si de
nombreux obstacles apparaîtront
certainement et si les défenseurs du
vieux général met toujours en avant
l'état de santé de pinochet commentaires
de philippe gassot on ne peut pas parler
de surprise l'information avait
transpiré depuis plus d'une semaine
le général pinochet n'est plus
intouchable par 14 voix pour 6 contre
les familles des victimes demandent que
la justice passe enfin la cour suprême a
confirmé la sentence de la cour d'appel
et a décidé le renvoi en justice ou
sénateurs pinochet
les familles des victimes de la
dictature triomphe même si beaucoup
d'entre elles n'y croyait plus à droite
c'est sans beaucoup de conviction que
l'on crie à l'innocence du vieux
dictateur
le nouveau président socialiste ricardo
lagos l'avait promis la justice ferait
partie de son mandat
c'est son titre de sénateur à vie qu'il
garantissait à augusto pinochet son
immunité
à présent la cour suprême du chili a
décidé qu'il pourra être jugé pour avoir
bafoué les droits de l'homme il répondra
de certains des crimes commis sous sa
dictature
déjà le tribunal de santiago avaient
voté une première fois par 13 voix
contre 9 la levée de l'immunité
l'ancien dictateur avait fait appel
devant la cour suprême
il n'aura pas été suivi même si la
gauche et la droite semble s entendre
pour ne pas raviver les blessures du
peuple
cent cinquante quatre plaintes ont été
déposées contre le général pinochet
la cour d'appel n'avait fondé sa demande
que sur les exactions de la seule
caravane de la mort nom donné à cette
unité militaire qui a parcouru le chili
de long en large dès octobre 73 afin
d'exécuter sans jugement les opposants
politiques
les meneurs cette caravane tragique
présentera son bilan
74 ennemis du régime assassiné les juges
considèrent qu'avec la caravane de
nombreux éléments établissent des liens
directs avec l'ancien dictateur au moins
la pinochet ne pourra pas dire je ne
savais pas ce qui a toujours été son
système de défense
et ce soir les réactions de satisfaction
se multiplient satisfaction en espagne
le juge garzon a longtemps réclamé en
vain l'extradition de pinochet
satisfaction bien sûr des familles des
victimes mais aussi satisfaction de
jacques chirac qui se réjouit de cette
décision de la justice chilienne encore
seul enquête se poursuit pour tenter
d'identifier les tueurs de jean michel
rossi et jean-claude fratacci une
autopsie des deux corps étaient prévus
cet après midi à bastia pour la pj corse
ainsi que la division nationale
antiterroriste de services s'en charger
de l'enquète 30 pistes sont envisagées
depuis la vengeance lié à la publication
du livre de jean michel roussier de
françois santoni jusqu'à l'assassinât
politique en passant par un règlement de
comptes plus personnelle en quête de nos
envoyés spéciaux stéphane breitner et
guillaume faudra une bonne heure à
l'abri du soleil
c'est le temps qu'ont pris les
enquêteurs pour reconstituer le double
meurtre
assistés du patron de la division
nationale antiterroriste
ils ont cherché à comprendre comment
jean michel rossi et jean-claude
fratacci ont été abattus le commando de
six hommes auraient tiré une
cinquantaine de coups de feu avec trois
types d'armes différents de deux angles
opposé les deux hommes n'ont eu aucune
chance
achevé de plusieurs balles dans la tête
ce soir les enquêteurs travaillent sur
plusieurs hypothèses
y at il une vengeance après la sortie du
livre de jean michel rossi et de
françois santoni
les deux anciens du mouvement à conques
holta y dénonce une certaine dérive
mafieuse des nationalistes autre
hypothèse un rapprochement avec deux
assassinats récents ceux de domine
sabelli et de paul grimaldi le mouvement
à matha corsa dont rossi et santoni
étaient soupçonnés d'être proches
avaient revendiqué l'exécution de
grimaldi
enfin les enquêteurs évoquent la
possibilité d'une action isolée de
certains nationalistes qui veulent
porter atteinte aux discussions engagées
avec matignon à l'île rousse
on est toujours sous le choc ce matin à
la lecture des journaux on n'ose pas
vraiment dire un mot pire parce qu'ils
n'y a envie de dire ce qu'il pense cet
anti nationaliste et maire de l'île
rousse depuis 30 ans
ce regain de violence inquiète il ya des
gosses des corses qu'ils se sentent
français qu'il ne souhaite pas qu'ils ne
veulent point qui souhaitent la paix la
concorde
maintenant quand on rentre dans la
violence il ya un moment n'est pas m
tout peut arriver
sur la plage les touristes poursuivre
leurs vacances comme si de rien n'était
demain les familles et les proches des
victimes se rendront au cimetière
ce double meurtre va-t-il réengager la
corse sur le chemin de la violence
peut-il mettre en péril la poursuite du
processus engagé à matignon certains le
redoutent même si la plupart des acteurs
corse ne le souhaite pas à commencer par
les nationalistes ajaccio le reportage
d'olivier theron et de rémi richard
ils ont voulu réagir au plus vite
condamnée et affirmé qu'ils ne sont pour
rien dans l'assassinât de jean michel
rossi les dix partis nationalistes qui
composent unita la structure qui a porté
les accords de matignon craignent que le
meurtre ne vienne tout remettre en
question ce que nous pensons ce que ce
sont des brigades vraisemblablement qui
viennent de l'extérieur et nous pensons
aussi qu'aujourd'hui le mouvement
national bien qu'il soit partagé entre
deux tendances
eh bien il ya comme des passerelles il
ya des discussions une question toute
action du mouvement national dans cette
affaire
les nationalistes écarte donc la thèse
nationaliste le milieu clandestins et
pourtant divisé il deviendrait de plus
en plus difficile à maîtriser
et c'est bien ce que décrivent et jean
michel rossi dans son livre pour solde
de tout compte écrit avec une autre
gloire du nationalisme françois santoni
les deux hommes bien qu'ils s'en
défendent serait à l'origine du
mouvement clandestin armata corsa pour
les nationalistes du nous tarde cet
assassinat serait plutôt le fait d'une
mafia voire même un hypothétique coup
tordu du gouvernement français je ne
vois pas pourquoi vous mettez en avant
le monde clandestin je pense qu'il ya
d'autres forces ne fût-ce en corse ou en
france qui ont intérêt à ce que les
processus encore éclat lesquels ceux qui
ne veulent pas que que ce soit l'ama qui
est que ce soit l'état avec un certain
nombre de personnages qui s'agitent
depuis des mois en disant il faut rien
faire en corse pour bloquer toutes les
évolutions à traiter une jean guy
talamoni de leader de corsica nacion
s'en prend aux détracteurs des accords
de matignon d accord conditionné par la
paix civile dans l'île tiendront sur
cette voie qui est la voie de la paix et
je crois que les politiciens français
qui cherche à récupérer les drames à
faire de l'exploitation de l'amour leur
fonds de commerce ont un an de plus à
bhl et ceux qui s'expriment aujourd'hui
sur ce terrain là dessus les
nationalistes en plein succès politiques
doivent apprendre à gérer le passif
clandestins de leur mouvement et le pire
serait que les amis de jean michel rossi
décide de se venger
et ce soir françois hollande pour le ps
considère que le processus de matignon
n'est pas remise en cause par ces
assassinats toujours en corse
deux des trois hommes gardé à vue depuis
la fusillade de bastia qui avait fait
quatre morts ont été déférés au parquet
pour être mise en examen il s'agirait
d'une simple dispute entre eux clients
du cabaret et puis un accident de la
circulation a fait trois morts et une
dizaine de blessés la nuit dernière dans
la région corte l'accident s'est produit
après un concert du groupe i muvrini le
mini cars transportant les techniciens
du concert a violemment percuté une
voiture ses freins n'aurait pas
fonctionné au pays basque espagnol la
violence a atteint un niveau rarement
égalé en l'espace de 24 heures trois
voitures piégées ont explosé l'une
visait le responsable du patronat dans
la province de gipuzkoa guipuzcoa la
tuer l'autre a explosé à bilbao alors
que quatre militants de letea sans doute
des poseurs de bombes étaient à bord de
la troisième était d'abord de la voiture
et puis la troisième bombe il ya
quelques heures a fait six blessés à
madrid le gouvernement espagnol parle de
barbarie et les nationalistes appellent
à une journée de ville claude sans père
ils venaient chercher sa voiture sur le
parking devant son entreprise à quelques
mètres un autre véhicule bourré
d'explosifs redémarrer accords thaï tué
sur le coup
les poseurs de bombes n'ont voulu
laisser aucune chance à cet homme
président du patronat de la province
basque du gipuzkoa
ces employés sont sous le choc pour
l'heure l'attentât n'a pas été
revendiqué mais pour la police aucun
doute ils portent bien la marque du
mouvement terroriste eta
rose et maria coréen était connu pour
ses prises de position favorables à une
solution négociée du conflit basque
comme beaucoup d'industriels il refusait
de payer l'impôt révolutionnaire en 30
ans de lutte armée le terrain assassiné
près de quarante chefs d'entreprise en
espagne
hier soir à bilbao les terroristes
basques n'ont pas eu le temps de déposer
leurs bombes
ils ont sauté avait lorsque les secours
sont arrivés les corps étaient
déchiquetés
il faudra plusieurs heures aux policiers
pour identifier quatre jeunes hommes
membres de l' eta
parmi eux taxi renteria le chef présumé
du commando biscaye
auteur de nombreux assassinats renteria
a été l'un des terroristes les plus
recherchés en espagne
devant cette nouvelle vague de violence
le pays tout entier une nouvelle fois
est indigne et écoeurée de théa et
contre le nationalisme ont pour le pays
basque
c'est même l'ennemi du pays basque il
faut le dire pour une fois aujourd'hui
seul le parti extrémiste proche du
mouvement terroriste n'a pas condamné le
tr comparer la mort de ces quatre jeunes
compagnons signifie que nous allons
continuer la guerre continuer à nous
battre en fin d'après midi le chef du
gouvernement rosa maria aznar a condamné
fermement l'assassinât de l'industrie
est le bas au même moment un nouvel
attentat s'est produit à madrid une
voiture piégée dans un quartier
résidentiel au nord de la capitale
dernier bilan six blessés parmi eux
deux enfants de trois et cinq ans
un attentat également à moscou en plein
centre ville dans un passage souterrain
à quelques encablures du palais du
kremlin
on compte pour l'instant huit morts et
des dizaines de blessés le président
poutine réunit ce soir ses ministres en
cellule de crise
le maire de moscou évoque la piste
tchétchène on se souvient que l'été
dernier cinq attentats attribués aux
tchétchènes avaient fait 293 morts en
russie
bernard lebrun news images nous commente
ces images venues de russie des images
assez difficile cette jeune maman jeanne
boulay d'une des sept blessés graves
provoquées dans l'explosion criant de
douleur remontée du souterrain elle est
rapidement évacué vers un hôpital
c'était une fin d'après midi très
ensoleillée 18 heures la sortie du
bureau au coeur d'un quartier très
commerçant tout indice suffisant pour
que la volonté de tuer soit évidente la
bombe
un engin d'un kilo et demi de tnt selon
la police étaient placées à l'intérieur
de ce passage souterrain qui traverse la
place pouchkine et conduit vers la
station de métro du même c'était une
terrible explosion et je crois bien
qu'il y avait des enfants dans le tunnel
les sauveteurs des mineurs sont
descendus sous la place selon certaines
sources une autre bombe aurait été
désamorcée à l'intérieur du souterrain
on parle d'un carnage au moins huit
piétons assassiné mais on ignore encore
si parmi eux il y avait des enfants
au total la police dénombre pour
l'instant plus de 27 blessés
le maire de moscou youri loujkov s'est
rendu sur place et a tout de suite
déclaré que l'origine de ce crime était
évident et je cite
ah mais c'est tout à fait une piste
tchétchène pour ses attentats
difficile pourtant de se prononcer si
vite sauf intentions politiques
quand on sait que la série d'attentats
de l'automne dernier ayant fait 293
morts n'a jamais été élucidé
bien sûr pour des raisons militaires
évidente boris eltsine accusent les
rebelles tchétchènes
alors manipulation politique et
électoral bataille rangée entre mafia et
un en passant son stylo et le pouvoir à
vladimir poutine
voorhees yalcin lui a transmis bien des
dossiers explosifs et peut-être ses
méthodes
un nouveau charnier découvert au kosovo
à des kilomètres au nord de pristina
selon les experts de la police
britannique qui se trouve sur place il y
aurait 50 6 cores les villageois eux
parlent de 75 personnes qui auraient
disparu les corps devraient être
transportés à pristina pour y être
autopsiés et alimenter éventuellement en
preuve le tribunal international de la
haye la situation reste toujours très
attendu dans cette province notamment au
nord dans les enclaves serbes
à tel point que msf a décidé de
suspendre ses activités
revenons maintenant en france et
précisément à calais où depuis le 1er
juillet les contrôles sont renforcés
dans la zone de fret il s'agit
d'endiguer autant que faire se peut le
flux d'immigration clandestine de la
france vers la grande bretagne pour ça
les autorités ont recours à un nouveau
procès d un détecteur de gaz carbonique
qui révèle dans les camions la présence
humaine en quête de thomas dandois et de
dominique maes contre 1 grâce à cet
appareil l'agent de prévention peut
désormais détecter l'air expiré
notre détecteur est en train de monter
anormal
comprenez une présence humaine car ce
que cherchent les équipes de sûreté ici
ce sont les passagers clandestins
il est 5 heures pour cet homme l'espoir
s'arrêtera là aujourd'hui
la police des frontières a été appelés
pour procéder à son interpellation
comme lui ils sont des dizaines dont des
femmes et des enfants
chaque nuit ils profitent de l'obscurité
pour tenter de se faufiler jusque dans
les camions ici une famille s'est fait
repéré par une patrouille de crs avant
même d'avoir pu passer le contrôle
là ça veut dire que riad ya une présence
à l'intérieur
6 heures cette fois ils sont nombreux
dix réfugiés entassés les uns à côté des
autres
à la fin de la nuit on comptera en tout
une quarantaine d'interpellations grâce
aux détecteurs dans les mêmes conditions
pour les chauffeurs routiers ce nouveau
système est un véritable soulagement
en angleterre ils sont systématiquement
mises à l'amande plus de 20 mille francs
par passager clandestin de contrôler
quoi
l'accueil clandestins rousseau c'est
préférable que la mort des chaires et
puis mon patron n'est pas très content
aujourd'hui un camion sur deux et
contrôlés au détecteur
mais le flot de réfugiés ne diminue pas
pour autant en un mois près de 1500
personnes ont ainsi été stoppés dans
leur tentative de gagner l'eldorado
anglais
les amis de christian marty sa famille
et des membres du personnel d'air france
ont rendu un dernier hommage au pilote
du concorde qui s'est écrasé le 25
juillet benes ses obsèques se sont
déroulées dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence question marty
était une forte personnalité connue de
tous et air france notamment pour ses
exploits sportifs
il laisse derrière lui une femme et deux
enfants plus de quinze jours après la
catastrophe et alors que tous les corps
des 113 victimes ont été maintenant
identifier et restituer à leurs familles
le travail des psychologues de la
cellule de soutien installé à roissy est
loin d'être terminée il leur faut en
effet prendre en compte et gérer le choc
vécu par tous les témoins de la
catastrophe reportage de mathias hillion
et de rémy poissonnier
passé juste après la tour le concorde en
feu a décollé sous ses yeux
quinze jours après le crash isabelle
durand a du mal à se défaire de cette
scène c'est en parlant avec ses
collègues qu'elle parvient peu à peu à
l'évacuer il y en a qui ont vu tout de
suite par rapport à la flamme qu' il
pouvait pas s'en sortir sans être un peu
plus de techniciens que d'autres y en a
d'autres qui ont vraiment très peur
parce que quand ils ont vu l'endroit où
il s'était écrasé mais il habite pas
loin donc il s'en disent que c'est chez
moi
ce que c'est sur ma maison j'ai ma
famille a roissy une permanence médico
psychologique est toujours en place pour
que les employés de l'aéroport qui
travaillaient l'après-midi de l'accident
puisse raconter ce qu'ils ont vécu
c'est à la décompression une fois que l'
affaire est terminée que les gens vont
vouloir en parler pour poser des
questions pour demander est ce que j'ai
été bon est-ce que j'ai bien réagi comme
il fallait que je réagisse se rassurer
juillet 95 une bombe explose dans une
rame du rer à saint-michel l'attentât
met en évidence les carences du suivi
psychologique des victimes et des
témoins de catastrophe mais cellule
d'urgence sont alors créés dans chaque
département responsable de l'unité du
val d'oise
carole du puits est en première ligne
depuis le drame de gonesse elle continue
aujourd'hui de recevoir des personnes
choquées par le crash
le but de la 2de l'entretien qui est
assez particulier c'est de faire
verbaliser les émotions le ressenti est
arrivé à ce que le sujet puisse
réinscrire ce qu'il a vécu dans son
histoire parce que souvent ça fait ça
fait vraiment ça fait rupture un soutien
psychologique qui devrait s'inscrire
dans la durée avec l'expérience des
catastrophes précédentes les psychiatres
s'attendent à ce que certains témoins du
crash connaisse une rechute dans les
semaines qui viennent
le gouvernement s'est engagé les 46
hectares de soja transgénique repérer
dans le sud est de la france vont être
détruits une décision dont se félicitent
les verts mais qui inquiète les
agriculteurs de la région qui se
demandent s'ils seront bien indemnisés
paigc et le roi jacky costes et inspecte
son champ une dernière fois d'ici
quelques jours ces plans de ce chat
seront arrachés sous ses ordres du
gouvernement
motif ces semences ont été contaminées
accidentellement par des ogm
d'où un certain découragement on a
travaillé toute la saison on nous
demande de détruire une récolte et c'est
parce que si on voit si on va être si on
va toucher quelque chose c'est tout le
travail qui qui perdu quoi
jacky costes et se fournit ici à l'union
des semences de provence la société
n'était pas au courant de la
contamination de ses produits
elle achète ces graines aux états unis
des graines uniquement issus de champ
sans modification génétique mais les
semences ont transité par l'italie c'est
donc pendant le transport qu'un mélange
avec du soja transgénique aurait eu lieu
la variété n'est pas une variété ogm
donc est une variété pure à ce niveau
lac lalla les impuretés qui lie à son
des impuretés venant d'autres graines de
soja d'autres variétés qui peuvent
éventuellement qui auraient pu
éventuellement être génétiquement
modifiés la coopérative a réuni ses
adhérents hier pour tenter de prouver sa
bonne foi
en tout sept de ses clients verront leur
soja arraché dans les prochains jours
parmi eux jacky coustet qui attend
d'être fixé sur le montant de
l'indemnisation du gouvernement environ
de trois jours après la découverte dans
les dunes de carcans plage du corps
d'une jeune touriste suisse morte
étranglée
les enquêteurs ont diffusé trois
portrait-robot il s'agirait de témoins
pour l'instant la piste du crime sexuel
fait partie des hypothèses envisagées
car une femme et franck le gaillard
depuis la découverte du corps de six
latrines leurs quarante gendarmes
poursuivent inlassablement leurs
investigations
c'est ici dans ce camping municipal que
la jeune fille passait ses vacances avec
ses parents les enquêteurs recueillent
les témoignages des campeurs il dispose
désormais des portraits robots de trois
témoins importants que j'en entends qui
nous
j que ce qui s'était passé et ils n'ont
donné ce matin portait robot la de
présumés et de science si on avait des
renseignements sur un petit souci on
voyait cet homme quoi si la gendarmerie
à l'entrée de la plage la photo de
cillia traîné le corps de la jeune fille
a été retrouvée samedi sur la dune
partiellement dévêtu et recouvert de
sable l'eau toxique confirme la thèse de
l'homicide volontaire par strangulation
qui les penseurs sous pour les filles
bon par exemple des phillies avaient
l'habitude de descendre sur les dunes
passé la soirée
mais après ce qui s'est passé donc ce
qu'il essayait de faire et laisser de
son groupe comme ça sont plus en
sécurité
les enquêteurs restent discrets pour
l'instant les circonstances de cet
homicide sont à déterminer
on ne sait pas encore si la jeune fille
a subi d'autres violences
des analyses complémentaires sont en
cours la situation sur le front des
incendies dans tout l'ouest américain
situation stable ce matin aux états unis
avec toujours une soixantaine de foyers
déclarés
rien ne semble pouvoir éteindre le feu
alors que le président clinton s'est
rendue sur place pour encourager les
secours au total vingt mille pompiers
sont mobilisés 700 véhicules 150 avions
hélicoptères pour lutter contre eux
cette gigantesque incendie mais le feu
continue sa progression inexorable il a
déjà détruit plus d'un million et demi
d'hectares de forêts etienne leenhardt
et notre envoyé spécial sur place
il est 10 heures du matin près de la
frontière entre la yahoo et le montana
mais on dirait qu'il est minuit
derrière l'épais rideau de fumée on ne
voit pas à vingt mètres lincendie qui
depuis deux jours ravagent la région
continue de s'étendre
le feu est trop gros il y a trop de
foyers que ne contrôlons plus donc notre
priorité n'est plus d'éteindre
l'incendié mais de sauver les maisons
par dizaines d'hectares aujourd'hui
encore les flammes détruisent tout sur
leur passage
certes le vent est un peu tombé mais il
fait toujours aussi chaud au bord de la
nationale coupé à la circulation
un couple attend avec fatalisme de
savoir si le ranch familial a été sauvée
quand on a vu que le feu avait sauté la
crète ont séduit bon il est temps de
partir et nous voilà un seul pompier
mais manchester isolés ils ont lu un
rayés de la carte
devant l'importance qu'ont pris les
incendies ces dernières semaines
consignes nationales a été donnée aux
pompiers de laisser brûler la forêt pour
ne se concentrer que sur la défense des
habitations et des entrepôts chaque
maison épargner ou presque par les
flammes et d'une pelle histoire pour les
500 pompiers qui depuis 48 heures arrose
copieusement à grands coups de neige
carbonique plus qui est menacée dans le
secteur
à chaque résident ensuite de décider
s'il veut rester ou pas quand les gens
acceptent de s'en aller le travail court
noué beaucoup plus facile on n'a pas
tous ces gens autour qui sont
hystériques et essaie de sauver leurs
maisons sont trop savoir comment s'y
prendre
de fait l'intensité des incendies de ces
derniers jours a été extrêmement
persuasif
aucun habitant n'a tenté le diable
chacun ayant compris bien vite que le
feu du siècle dans l'ouest américain et
est affaire de spécialistes et c'est
sans doute la plus grande fierté des
centaines de pompiers venus combattre
les feux ici dans l'état du montana
ces incendies les plus graves que la
région ait connue depuis plus de 50 ans
n'ont jusqu'ici fait aucune victime mais
au fil des jours on en vient à se
demander ce qu'un incendie de cette
ampleur peut provoquer pour
l'environnement bien sûr des à 110
ravagent régulièrement les forêts du
grand ouest américain
mais rarement à une telle échelle
explications de sébastien héroux et
d'hélène dernier rien ne semble pouvoir
arrêter ces flammes
l'être humain est dépassé aux etats unis
un million cinq cent mille hectares
répartis sur onze états ont déjà brûlé
si pour les scientifiques un feu n'est
pas vraiment mauvais en soi car il
permet de régénérer la forêt la
fréquence des incendies a de quoi
inquiéter
on est une décade qui est à vue une
fréquence de feu comme on en a jamais vu
depuis 200 ans
or ces feux on sait que 100 d'origine
naturelle
donc ils sont directement liées au
climat les scientifiques sont de plus en
plus convaincus du lien entre les feux
de forêt et le réchauffement de la
planète
en tout cas depuis la fin des années 80
les incendies se multiplient aux etats
unis en indonésie et en russie
la faune et la flore de ces régions ont
été forcément perturbé l'hôte allemand
lorsque la forêt disparaît il est
évident que les conditions vont être
différentes les grands particulier pour
tout ce qui est à l'humilité est une
série donc le climat localement va
changer le temps que la forêt se
restaurent la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est est ce que la forêt va
pouvoir se restaurer la destruction de
ces forêts et donc une catastrophe
écologique pour l'ouest américain mais
elle ne devrait pas avoir de
conséquences sur le climat mondial en
france au lendemain d'un accident mortel
sur la côte d'azur entre un jet ski et
un hors-bord nathalie jourdan hervé
pozzo auront suivi une opération de
contrôles en mer dans la région de nice
leur reportage en baie d'antibes
quand roland baie d'antibes la vedette
des douanes à raison d'un scooter ces
fusées de détresse sont périmés 3,17
l'infraction n'est pas rare mais la plus
fréquente est le défaut de permis mer
obligatoire pour ce type d'engin
dès le départ ils pensent que ce n'est
pas nécessaire dès l'instant où ils sont
persuadés que ce véhicule nautiques à
moteur ce qu'on appelle habituellement
le scooter des mers
mais pour eux n'est pas un bateau n'est
pas un loyer pour eux sont persuadés ne
pas être dangereux
depuis les accidents série du début des
années 90 l'utilisation des scooters des
mers est strictement réglementée outre
la détention d'un permis
l'âge minimum du conducteur est fixé à
16 ans opérait au délabrement
au delà des 300 mètres sans dépasser le
milieu nautique là le véhicule parfois
doté de 100 chevaux n'est soumis à
aucune limitation de vitesse le danger
c'est la collision est effectivement il
ya des engins maintenant qu'ils sont
très puissants qui vont à savoir plus
100 km/heure sur le voir plus hélas ce
moment là il est vrai qu'on peut perdre
le contrôle à 7,6 à laval angers c'est
dangereux
non non moi parce qu'on est prudent on
va pas comme des fous et on risque pas
mais pour certains utilisateurs en quête
de sensations fortes ce sport de glisse
n'est pas compatible avec la prudence
les professionnels de la sécurité en mer
essaieront encore de les convaincre du
contraire la sécurité aussi en montagne
on n'insistera jamais assez sur les
précautions à prendre
aussi bien en termes de consultation de
la météo que en termes de choix du
matériel à matériel qui est testée par
des professionnels en laboratoire et
aussi sur le terrain le reportage près
de chamonix
loïc de la mornais et christian galley
vous qui avez essayé l' escalade
n'avez-vous jamais eu peur d'une corde
et crac d'une sangle qui vous lâchent
toutes ces petites choses qui ne vous
retiennent plus face au vide
voici la salle de torture du matériel d'
escalade
nous sommes au laboratoire de l'école
nationale de ski et d'alpinisme
ici les ingénieurs testent la résistance
et l'efficacité des équipements qui
garantissent la survie des grimpeurs
montagne on a la chance maintenant on
peut tomber
on a le droit à l'erreur et donc le
droit à l'erreur pourquoi parce que les
corps ne casse pas parce que les cordes
sont souples et vaut à mme ortiz parce
que les baudriers ne casse pas parce que
les pythons sont bons et testé et ses
cordes et mousquetons python chaussures
tous les prototypes des fabricants sont
testés par ce laboratoire indépendant
histoire de vérifier par exemple que les
inquiétants bruits de craquements de ce
baudriller
n'auront pas d'une fois pendu en l'air à
3000 m d'altitude
mais avant la mise sur le marché
subsiste une autre étape en grandeur
nature cette fois françois et françoise
son testeur de matériel d' escalade
au programme aujourd'hui l'examen d'un
nouveau prototype de baudriers certain
nombre de matériels qui peuvent très
bien marché dans une salle dans le
bureau d'études on est au chaud et acier
un bureau ça fonctionne très bien que
tout d'un coup en haute montagne dans
des situations plus compliquées
il fait mauvais il fait froid on
manipule avec des gants on n'est pas
dans des positions confortables
ça va devenir très difficile à utiliser
il faut vérifier si le baudrier et
confortable s'ils ne cisaille pas les
jambes aussi le retient bien le corps de
l'alpiniste petit test de chute réussi
ce soir françois et françoise enverront
leur rapport par email aux ingénieurs
d'une usine de grenoble
de quoi permettre aux futurs
utilisateurs de grimper au côté du mont
blanc en toute sérénité
ou presque le parolier de johnny
hallyday de sylvie vartan de michel
sardou est mort à l'âge de 73 ans gilles
tibo était aussi l'un des auteurs avec
l'autre françois de la chanson comme
d'habitude un tube qui a fait le tour du
monde et qui était interne qui a été
interprété par les plus grands histoire
d'une chanson avec karim annuel luneau
et jean-françois chevet
cette chanson n'avait peut-être l'air de
rien comme ça chantait par claude
françois un certain automne 67 et
pourtant elle allait s'inscrire ni plus
ni moins dans le patrimoine de
l'humanité
aujourd'hui on peut parier sans trop se
tromper que l'être humain sur deux a au
moins une fois dans sa vie en tant nui
satiné l'auditif cocorico pour une fois
élu claude françois n'était pas seule à
ses côtés jacques revaux et surtout
gilles tibo pour le texte ont participé
à l'édification de ce monument c'est
dans les couloirs des archives de radio
france que l'on peut trouver quelques un
des rares exemplaires originaux de comme
d'habitude
voilà ce transfert est assez triste et
donc il y avait écrit commencé à écrire
une chanson comme ça de tristesse de
chagrin d'amour et j'ai lu thibault la
la fabrique et la chanson l'art tricoter
techniquement voilà jacques revaux a
fait la musique assez vite ça s'est
passé assez vite autour de la piscine
comme ça en était la carrière
internationale de ce tube n'a vraiment
commencé que lorsqu'un certain frank
sinatra s'il est approprié
agacé
dès lors pour le monde comme d'habitude
ce sera my way avant l'achat
depuis sa naissance celle thibault n'a
été que de loin associé à son oeuvre
une oeuvre qui a pourtant rapporté à ses
trois coauteurs près de 300 millions de
francs depuis sa création d'oeuvres de
tous les superlatifs
une oeuvre adaptée plus de 2500 emplois
dans le monde entier
voilà c'est bientôt la fin de ce journal
je vous en rappelle les deux principales
informations
d'abord un coup de théâtre au chili avec
la décision de la cour suprême de lever
l'immunité parlementaire du général
pinochet l'ancien dictateur pourrait
donc être jugé là même où un procès
paraissait impossible
et puis ce coup de tonnerre sur le tour
de france près de la moitié des
échantillons urinaires prélevés sur les
coureurs pendant le tour comprenait des
produits dopants beaucoup le justifie
par des certificats médicaux et la
suspicion revient à grands pas dans un
instant la météo avec nathalie rihouet
ces horreurs 25 le dernier journal ce
sera alexandre kara à 13 heures laurence
ostolaza et enfin leur mari et quant à
moi j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain aux alentours de 20h bonne soirée
sur france 2
tout